الاني لا مستجدات الانتخابات التشريعيه في
تونس حيث ارجحت الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات تنظيم دوره ثانيه في اغلب
الدوائر بعد تسجيل نسبه مشاركه هي الاضعف
في الانتخابات التونسيه منذ الثوره
مزيد من التفاصيل يعرضه لنا من المركز
الاعلامي لهيئه الانتخابات في تونس مدير
مكتب الجزيره لطفي حجي لطفي بماذا تخبرنا
هذه النتائج
بالفعل جلال هو النتائج الناطقه بذاتها من
حيث ااه ضعف المشاركه ومن حيث اعاده همم
الدوره الثانيه في 133 دائره حسب ما قالت
لي المنصري الناطق الرسمي الهيئه هناك
واحد و20 فقط فاز وفي هذه الانتخابات مع
10 نوفازه بطريقه لانهم تقدموا بمفردهم في
دوائهم لذلك ستضطر الى دوله ثانيه في 130
دائره يعني في اغلب الدوائر اذا تعتبرنا
ان عدد دوائر
161 بين بين الداخل والخارج هناك 10 دوائر
في الخارج لم يتقدم فيها سبعه همم
جزئيه هذه النتائج في يومها الثالث تثيره
ردود فعل مخ سواق من الهيئات المراقبه
للانتخابات او كذلك من الاحزاب السياسيه
بالنسبه
للهيئات مراقبه الانتخابات والتي تقدم
تاريخ تقاريرها بصفه همم مستمره كان لافته
الموقف الذي اعلنه هيئه كارت مركز كارت
لمراقبه الانتخابات هذا اليوم المتمثل في
نقد شديد للمسار الانتخابي لانه يعتبر ان
القانون الانتخابي ثابته عديد من الهنيات
وكذلك على مستوى همم التغطيه همم
الانتخابيه ومستوى الحوار المعدوم الذي
سبق هذا الانتخابات وهو قد الى هذه نتائج
لذلك اقترح ما يشبه خريطه تبدا اساسا
بتغيير القانون الانتخابي والنظام
الانتخابي والمطالبه بهيئه ان همم مستقله
للانتخابات ومزيد التقارب بين السلطات
السياسيه والقانونيه واعطاء مزيده من
استقلال السلطه التشريعيه هذا في جانب
الهيئه المراقبه في بكذلك نلاحظ انه رغم
اختلاف المواد السياسيه للاحذيه بربما في
القضايا المحاليل هذا هناك التقاط في نقطه
في هذه
الانتخابات وهو الدعوه الى انتخابات
رئاسيه مبكرا لوضع حد لهذا ما يعتبرون
الفشل لان الانتخابات تؤثر على فشل مسار
25 يوليو بالنسبه اليهم والذي اعتبره
الرئيس سعيد عندما قام باجراءته الاستثناء
يعتبرهم مخرجا لهذا البلاد بل منعرج
تاريخيا جديده وهم يقولون ان هذه
الانتخابات ان هذا المسار لا سند شعبيه له
كما بين من قبله والاستفتاء على
الدستور هيئه الانتخابات همم اعترفت على
لساني انا ابراهيم رئيسها ماهر جديد على
ان المقاطعه التي بعثت اليها الانتخابات
للاحذيه ابداعات الى الاحزاب والسجائر لها
انصار والاحزاب جسيمه كبيره في نتيجه
الانتخابات نستمع ما قاله ماهر شديدي في
هذا الصدق
الاحزاب المعروفه التقليديه المعروفه في
الساحه السياسيه قاطعت الانتخابات هذا من
هذا من منهم كروش على شيء يتغشوا عليه
خاطر انا نقول في كلام كلام واقعي الاحزاب
اللي شاركت في الانتخابات صحيح صحيح عندها
اهميه في السياحه السياسيه ولكن ما هيش
الاحزاب اللي احنا نعرفها ماهيش ان
الاحزاب اللي نعرفها احنا في ال- همم في
الساحه السياسيه
شكرا لك يا لطفي حجه في تونس